おはようございますはめ社長です
えー飲みすぎましたすいませんちょっと
飲みすぎててテンションがや低いんです
けども皆さんポストイットという付箋ご
存知でしょうかこちらねジム用品の1つな
んですけどポストイット今年弱と書いて
あるんですけどペタって貼れるんですよ
こうやって貼ると結構粘着力強くてこう物
とか机のどこかにこうやって貼ってこうに
なんか重要なこととか忘れちゃいけない
ことを書くと忘れにくくなったりするって
いうめちゃくちゃ使い勝手のにこういう
ジム品があるんですけども結構さっと
貼れるんですよ人の体とかにもこうパ
みたいなさって貼れるんでだめださっと
貼れるんでこれ寝てる人にどれだけ晴れる
のかなっていう検証記をしてみたいと思い
ますえそのためにですね私昨日アホほど
飲みました後輩のタメという男がいるん
ですけどもこいつ眠りがめちゃくちゃ深い
んですよ何年か前にもすごい眠りの深さを
利用して動画を何本か撮ってみたんです
けどもターゲットが眠りが深い男だったら
もう起きるまで全身晴れるんじゃないかと
思いまして忘れないように物事気づくよう
に気づくために貼るポストイットカードを
貼っても貼っても気づくべきものに気づか
ないというとてもね矛盾が生じると思って
昨日夜中からずっと後輩とお酒を飲み
まくりましたVTRどうぞゴシ
レ
やばい
はえあれえ俺こっちっすよねるすよねあれ
そうだっけはいええどっちだだっけ
俺そういいよいいよいい勝負なんじゃない
いい勝負なんじゃパラバやパラヤパラバや
ヘイどどんどんどんどどんどんどん
ててはいありがとうございわどんどん
どんどんはいどんどんどんどんた行くぞ
行くぞはい大丈夫こっちなりこっちなりよ
わあピこっちこっちよ決めてやってくれる
かはいもちろんですやらしください激たよ
知ってこいはい行きます休む何休む何やん
ならいいやんならいいよ俺やんなりやるよ
行けため
おらわか
高あるからさいいのかそれでお違サ首狙い
にかた首はいなんで俺本当よく起きれたな
と思いまして今日めっちゃ眠いし頭痛い
ですが眠りの深い男がさらに眠りが深く
なっている状態今なら気づかせるための
ポストどんだけ貼っても気づかないんじゃ
ないかと思いまして寝てる人にポスト
イット何枚貼れるか検証していきたいと
思いますかなりの1000枚ぐらいポスト
イット準備したのでなくなることはないと
思います早速現場に急行したいと思います
では
[拍手]
[音楽]
行こう
あ
[音楽]
T
K
[音楽]
あ
JA
[音楽]
あ
ったて
動かずに寝てなさい分かった動かずに
寝れる動かずに寝れる
かため
ため動かずに
寝れる動かずに寝れるか
いでできるなよし偉いぞ動かずに寝るんだ
ぞ動かずにだったらずっと寝てられるから
な
分かった
寝れる寝れるたためん
ためん動かずに
寝れる
[音楽]
ためん
ああ
[音楽]
検証終了ですさすがにこれはもう無理
でしょ
ためおはようはい
おはよう何ですかこれ
すごいおはようおはようござい
ます
もう無理でしょもう無理でしょ再起不能の
願いとなはいというわけで検証の結果眠り
が深い人に付箋ポストイットは合計541
枚つけることができまし
たいや結構強制的に寝りを止めたりとか
無理言い聞かせて動かせねめるとか言って
ちょっと特殊な方法を引きてやってみたん
ですけどもまあまあなかなか貼ることが
できほ全身張ることができましたがやっぱ
寝り1つでね本当に変わる地球の火山活動
と一緒ですねこう近く変動1つで突然こう
やって新しい大陸ができたりするのでチリ
の勉強にもなりました無理でしょここまで
行くとぐっちゃぐちゃだしもうどうしよう
もないよこれはめこのまま動かず
寝れるよしもうちょっと張ってみるかた寝
てる寝てる
うしないんだ出
たらあ動いちゃだめよね動かず寝れるいい
子
[音楽]
だ全身晴れまし
たはいちょっと見ていきましょうかすごい
よこの逆側の見えない部分もしっかり
モーラさせていただきました大丈夫
ここから見たらもう怖いもんもう結構感動
のレベルじゃないでしょうかこれは無限
にメモ取れますかねため起きてはい
おはようちょっとどうなってる
体や
ばやっ
ば青いです体が地球
はです地球は